hey there folks welcome to sector G are
live broadcasting venue here at PAX
Prime I'm your host Chris waters let me
hear from the audience who's here eating
a bunch of bacon and ready to watch a
live show that was way luck I'm
impressed that was way later than I
expected you guys are great ah joining
me on the couch here we got Justin hey
walls and Peter Brown hi guys we're big
fans of bacon yeah i'm more of a sausage
man you're me of a sausage man
definitely more of a sausage man we can
tell that by looking at it so we're
gonna kick off the show today pax prime
usually not a place more like it a whole
ton of news comes out but lo and behold
on Friday Nintendo was it a Nintendo
Direct they always do the Nintendo
Direct it wasn't in Findo direct it's
not related to pax at all this all this
came out before packs really and this is
a japan-only event where they announced
a new 3ds a new 3d and it's literally
called new 3ds no it's not it is that's
it it is no letters after another armlet
so it can get a standard new 3ds or the
new 3ds over there the XL is called the
LL and so you can get the new 3ds ll and
it has some extra buttons extra but yeah
me two extra shoulder buttons gonna be
on this thing it's a has an extra analog
nub okay and you say nub it does that
mean it's different from the sort of
path it's like yeah it literally is like
a little rubber nub that's probably
gonna fit in the center of your thumb
and that's about it you're gonna lose it
being like laptops yes your old laptop
and it you know it's something that's
made for the dual stick game games that
need that that dual analog control and
one of them is Xenoblade yeah that the
Wii U game from monolith oh yeah it's
get ported it's only gonna work on the
new 3ds and for Japan they're gonna get
that really soon it's coming out in
October America in the UK maybe in 2015
maybe sometime the future well I they're
probably gonna see how well it does over
there joking you know see what kind of
reception something like that gets but
it is it does have a faster processor
it's supposed to have better 3d from
what we've been told where you know when
you're holding your 3ds now you
to like get that perfect angle and if
you move your head slightly you just get
a massive headache this one's supposed
to just get that 3d effect no matter how
you're holding it oh really likes to it
yet but uh Xenoblade that was a huge RPG
yeah and people loved that one it was
definitely beloved in the gamespot
office I you figured I mean that seems
like a great thing to have on a portable
handheld I'm yet you know Monster Hunter
has thrived on handhelds as well I
prefer those longer experiences on a
handheld something that you can take
with you that you don't have to worry
about sitting in front of your TV or
hours an hour when the game is designed
for it to it has so many side quests I
want to say like a few hundred and all
of those will blast you just about a few
minutes right so you could just imagine
playing one of those on the go you're
done come back later little shell you're
good yeah and one of the other reasons
that they're going through this redesign
is because you have those amiibo figures
that are coming out really soon yeah and
this one's gonna have a built-in NFC
reader so right now for the regular 3ds
there's gonna be an adapter that you'll
be able to get in the US and if you get
one of the emmy bows for i think it only
works for smash brothers so far you get
the adapter and you'll be able to use it
but in japan you'll have a system that
you just place it onto and it'll work
right away have the amigos started
rolling out yet when did they release
cuz we've been hearing about him for a
while the release date right now is like
tentative on amazon is december 31st
2014 so basically no one knows yet yeah
it's got all this year no no it's
possible oh really yeah we're does not
positive win all right I are you guys to
meet those are the little figurines what
they didn't talk too much about of Evo's
at the NFC event but they did talk about
a couple other games right well so we
have some games on the show floor just
like any other any of these other shows
we ought to be three stuff a lot of
games com stuff and if you're on the
show floor everyone is playing smash
brothers that is you know one of the
most exciting games to play but there's
some other things to check out and one
of those is a
real warriors Hyrule warriors yeah they
have a bunch of chaos to play there has
anybody here played Hyrule warriors yet
that guy has run up to guys smash
brothers for the wii u you guys try that
out your people yeah are popular is it
completely honest I I hate warriors
games when I user reviews editor and the
Warriors games were the things that we
gave people as punishment really reviva
we were like vindictively like listen
man your last assignment was late like
you must know what's gonna happen it's
in your code of conduct you have to
review the next warriors game it's
warrior stuff but I'm actually a little
bit more sold on this because it does
have that that whole Zelda trapping and
the thing that we got to do in this time
as you can see on the screen was we got
to play around with Gannon and this was
a free play mode it's not necessarily a
part of this story like this because you
might see link running around a few in
some of these other sections but you'll
be able to go back two stages the
already beat and once you unlock some of
these characters and one of them being
Gannon you can play through the game
with him and take on a giant purple
plant that barfs plants and is called
man Andy oh I don't manhandle it man
handler hey anyways so you got a chance
to play it Peter yeah well I've played
in the past I didn't play it at this
show but I mean look it really is a
warrior's game through and through it
has a lot of the Zelda you know like
touches like the music like these little
things that remind you of Zelda yeah so
that kind of is like a nice little thing
that like draws out of Pavlovian the
response but you know I mean you kind of
have to have an affinity for this sort
of game this sort of game being like I'm
a powerful hero pitted against endless
hordes of enemies i can just shred
through them pretty easy ardd I is
another big button masher yeah sure you
know i like to use more words when less
define it's an interesting experiment
though because Nintendo is not usually
one to sort of lend out its properties
its try it in the past but working with
co e is definitely unusual but those
games are really really popular in Japan
mm-hmm we're probably gonna see a lot
more of these brands going out to maybe
be worked on by some other developers
yeah we certainly saw it last week with
the announcement of pokken
Hogan an open tournament which is Tekken
flush Pokemon so pokin know puts but to
be clear there are no Tekken characters
it's not going to play exactly like
tekken but it's made by the same team
run by the same director katsuhiro
harada and it's hitting japanese arcades
first i was really interesting thing
intendo rarely dabbles in arcades these
days I think maybe once in a while
there's a mario kart or an f-zero game
uh-huh super rare so so and that's you
play as the pokemon in a fighting game
but that was no one's gotten their hands
on that yet they just announced ya know
it's only announced it and we're
assuming that's probably only going to
be fighting type Pokemon you're not
necessarily gonna be able to be people
they said that's not true always the now
Jeff do you get to be pikachu job a
newsman like a big muscly Pikachu yeah
no honestly it's not just a fighting
type pokemon that's what they showed off
probably just to give people a real
sense for you know what the action is
going to be like but they were on record
saying I know we're gonna be expanding
just beyond those types I mean I can't
imagine you would launch a Pokemon
fighting game and there would be no
Pikachu yeah I think it'll be like for
Pikachu standing on top of one another
like in a trench coat yeah it mega chu
that's what it's gone alright so this is
Hyrule warriors that's playable is that
is this coming out this year or is this
yeah yes slated for I think it's coming
yeah coming this fall people will be
able to play it very soon and this was
also put together with Team Ninja as you
can see maybe by the character design
and it's not totally a standard Nintendo
that we see a little team ninja
influence there I think a small amount
of it's not that small you might you
might be able to tell what part they had
a head of hinted influencing they're not
the small part haha I so that but there
you know Team Ninja is sort of a combat
focus studio yeah they they're fighting
I guess there I know would be their
contribution they're definitely known
for fighting and for things like dead or
alive yep yes they are ya so Hyrule
warriors is out on the pack show floor
focusing play it here what else what's
another sort of game they've they got
out there there's one called fantasy
life enjoy life yeah is lucky is a game
from level 5 below also clear level
thing developer well it's being
published by level 5 and lashendo okay
now developed with my brownie brown
there 100k who did the
latent section of the RPG section of one
of the latent games they also helped
develop mother 3 yeah they made a mana
game on Game Boy Advance and that first
came out so they they have a really good
pedigree of making these fun RPGs and
when you're playing it there's a game
cut that came out recently I don't think
it really resonates with our readers
Disney magical life though it is a lot
of my life it sounds wonderful who
doesn't want to live the Disney magical
life oh this isn't like that but with a
more standard fantasy type trappings
where you can take on different classes
and be you know a warrior or a paladin
or maybe a cook or a blacksmith so this
the in this gameplay footage the person
just changed to their life to a
blacksmith get your and you're literally
living out a fantasy life that easy just
let just like in real life you decide I
want to be a paladin today guess I'll be
paladin and it kind of borrows some
stuff from final fantasy 11 where you
can take on these classes and level up
in them and then when you want to change
over to something else you still have
some of the abilities from there it's
but you're not going to lose all the
progress that you already made so you
can you'll start from level 1 as a cook
I'm still have all the stuff that you
did as a paladin you're not gonna and
then if you choose to be a blacksmith
you're not going to forget how to make
lasagna yeah all right so is it I mean
is it like Animal Crossing esque at all
in terms of the sort of day-to-day just
doing tasks around town kind of thing or
their adventures to go on if you're an
adventurer it I guess you could call it
like an animal crossing RPG because
there are there is a combat element
there are things to do outside of just
the Animal Crossing being a more of a
life experience there's coasties marma
this is more of a game if there is a
Cooking Mama type aspect where if you're
the if you're the blacksmith and you're
gonna make your sword you do have to do
some timing type events to get it just
right and if you do it really well it'll
have like a little star thing that came
up with like oh you made a really good
ladle delightful and then you decorate
your home Peter I know you're huge on
interior design don't get me started
also this one another 3ds game I was it
a is that later for movies this years
I've recently announced no it's not
recently announced this has actually
been out in Japan for the last year I'm
really up on my Japanese game releases
as you
so but it's something that I think will
resonate will find an audience here in
the states it's coming out in October
I'm personally set like as someone who
put hundreds of hours into animal
crossing which I probably shouldn't
admit out loud I I'm very excited to
play this but probably not a game for
everyone I you can look at it and see
like it's kind of cartoony if you're
into that kind of collecting and it may
be playing with friends and trading
stuff it kind of fun things may be a way
like come on I mean there is the hold
not a game for everyone that's I mean
there's no game that's for everyone
woman I say that for tetris if you don't
interest no holman there's a distinct
lack of decapitations there's probably
very little blood coming out when you
slice through people you're not allowed
to slice through people no I mean it
doesn't seem like a real slice through
people kind of game what we see some
mining going on yeah if you explore
caves and forests for lots of enemies
and things like that to fight it's a
it's a weird it's an interesting mix of
genres that I think it'll be a lot of
fun neat alright so some Nintendo games
on display here new 3ds coming down the
pipe what do you guys think of sort of
Nintendo what's what are you looking
forward to in the Nintendo verse over
the coming months like and you'll you
download some Bayonetta 2 or you looking
forward to getting your smash on
anything personally exciting for you
guys well smashes is of course the
dominant game when you come to something
like pax even at e3 like just seeing the
level excite of excitement the number of
people just gathered around these
stations 3 it's gonna come out on 3ds
first which is not you know it's not the
best version of the game like we're
definitely beat holding it we're still
waiting for that wii u version but 3d s
is still a lot of fun and you know you
get around you like we get around and
play mario kart you get around and play
smash but you know the screen size
challenge you'll probably want an ll for
that one or XL yeah yeah XL is gonna
help a lot and it's just such a wide
array of Fighters I know some of them
have been leaked we're not totally sure
how how much we can trust those those
reports that have come out but they look
really realistic and one of those that
they came out was the duck hunt dog the
duck hunt dog and I don't know if this
is true or not but I am I'm really
excited to play as the duck hunt dog if
this is real because I heard someone
saying like he's a dog that you run
around you can throw ducks at people
I imagine his final smash is going to be
like having the reticule on screen and
being able to shoot at people and then
at the end he just comes up a gold
ridiculous thing like smashes ever as a
kid like smash brothers is a ridiculous
game and like that just submits it
gloriously ridiculous what about you
paid or anything on your radar you know
what man I just want more virtual
console games nintendo did such a good
job on the wii and like they're kind of
getting better at doing it with the 3ds
now the wii u is still flagging i just
want the entire library back i know
there's a lot of licensing issues but
yeah i'm a big fan of Nintendo's legacy
stuff and the games that were built for
their systems so personally speaking or
big stuff is okay i'm not the biggest
smash fan but i think man if they spent
more time their virtual console maybe
they wouldn't be in so much trouble
financially i love to say it wasn't
video people of that the old nintendo
stuff yeah bring it out on throttle
virtual console and they have the second
screen experience with the wii u
controller it's perfect for that like
it's a massive screen you can play these
little games on what they need to do
they need to integrate these systems
together so that if you buy a game on
the 3ds it's gonna carry over to the wii
u you don't have to buy like three
copies of mega man you know what they
might do and i'm saying this only
because it has all the extra buttons and
the analog stick they might phase out
the gamepad from the wii u and make the
new XL an optional gamepad an optional
gamepad for them yeah i like the way you
think it's got a stronger cpu it's got
more buttons what more do you need you
just need more button simply seriously
and it's got like a it's got like a
really nice dock that they were avard
they were showing as well if they do
that i'll be really excited about that
because i want a wii u but I kind of
don't like the gamepad and its current
iteration yep so it was really funny
when they announced it Peter but I
showed Peter as well and he was like oh
that looks really cool and then they
showed the doc he was like oh my god did
you see that dog I'm gonna sucker for
docs what can i say i love dogs from
Nintendo the new 3ds Justin hey Walt
Peter Brown thank you guys so much for
chatting a little Nintendo uh I'll
release you into the packs wilds to play
games or eat some board games or try to
get more pins I know you're a pinche sir
I am I have a that makes it sound dirty
and wrong it is a little dirty but not
wrong
you